Euron Greyjoy:When Aegon finally saw the monstrous
castle, he asked for parley.
Harren granted it.
Valyria had been the greatest empire the world
had ever seen.
Harren wanted to piss on its ashes.
Viserys Targaryen: (as Aegon) "Yield now,
and you may remain Lord of the Iron Islands.
Yield now, and your sons will live to rule
after you.
You see my army outside your walls.
You see my dragons."
Euron: (as Harren) "What is outside my walls
is of no concern.
Those walls are strong and thick."
Viserys: (as Aegon) "Dragons fly."
Euron: (as Harren) "But stone doesn't burn."
Viserys: (as Aegon) "When the sun sets, your
line shall end."
Euron: Harren spat and returned to his castle.
Once inside, he promised lands, riches, and
Tully's daughters to whoever could bring down
Aegon or his dragon.
As the sun sank below the horizon, all Harren's
men patrolled the battlements, hearing wings
in every gust of wind.
But the moon rose and sank, and no dragon
appeared.
Viserys: While the ironborn were ringing the
battlements, Aegon drove his dragon Balerion
higher and higher in the night sky, so that
even the great castle of Harrenhal looked
like an anthill below them.
Then they plunged straight into the castle,
well inside the guarded walls.
The five towers of Harrenhal reached towards
Aegon like a hand.
Balerion opened his mouth and bathed all the
fingers in flame.
Euron: Harren was right.
Stone doesn't burn, but men do, even when
they're ironborn.
The dragon blasted my ancestors into ash that
choked the survivors when they screamed.
Harren's soldiers leapt from the battlements
and died.
They huddled against the walls and died.
They fled across the yard and died.
Harren and his sons took shelter inside the
castle.
The stone didn't burn, but as Balerion blasted
it with fire, it glowed white-hot.
The world's greatest castle became the world's
greatest oven, baking the last of House Hoare
within it.
Viserys: Outside the castle walls, the towers
of Harrenhal glowed red against the night
and began to twist and melt like five huge
candles, with liquid stone trickling down
their sides like wax.
The next morning, Aegon forged a new Riverlands.
He named the rebel Edmyn Tully as his Lord
Paramount of the Trident and had the other
riverlords swear him fealty as their new liege.
For centuries, House Hoare had terrorized
the Riverlands.
Under House Tully, the Riverlands would, at
last, return to peace and prosperity.
After the castle cooled enough to allow men
inside, Aegon ventured into the ruin he had
made of Harrenhal.
He saw the ashen bodies, the scorched stone,
and the mangled and melted swords of his former
enemies.
To his men's confusion, he ordered these useless
swords collected and sent to his Aegonfort.
Theon Greyjoy: When Aegon and his dragons
burned Harren the Black and all his sons at
Harrenhal, the days when men feared the sight
of our longships were over.
Aegon would not permit marauders and raiders
in his Seven Kingdoms.
With Harren died our empire and the Old Way
that forged it.
But what is dead may never die.
Six years after Robert Baratheon won his crown,
my father, Balon Greyjoy, sought to restore
our ancient rights.
He declared the Iron Islands independent,
and himself its king and sent the Iron Fleet
in a daring raid on Lannisport where they
burned the Lannister ships at anchor, making
us unchallenged in the Sunset Sea.
This was the seed of our undoing.
My eldest brother, Rodrik, led a frontal assault
on Seagard, a town built to protect the mainland
from us.
After ferocious fighting beneath the city
walls, he was slain by Lord Jason Mallister,
and his men defeated.
By this time, Stannis Baratheon had brought
Robert's fleet around Westeros and somehow
managed to trap the Iron Fleet at Fair Isle,
smashing it.
Robert's victory was now all but assured,
yet we made him bleed for each island.
Stannis Baratheon captured Great Wyk, the
largest of the Iron Islands, and Ser Barristan
Selmy himself subdued Old Wyk.
Robert and Lord Eddard Stark led the main
assault against the island of Pyke.
They razed the town of Lordsport to the ground
before Robert turned his full fury on our
family's stronghold.
When they breached the walls, the first through
was Thoros of Myr with his ridiculous flaming
sword, followed by every minor lord of Westeros
hungering for glory.
My other brother, Maron, was killed when the
siege engines brought down a tower on his
head.
I was now my father's only living son and
heir to the Iron Islands.
When my father saw that his cause was lost,
he wisely conceded defeat to Robert, who otherwise
would have pulled down our castle stone by
stone with us in it.
As my father said to me then, "No man has
ever died from bending his knee.
He who kneels may rise again, blade in hand.
He who'll not kneel stays dead, stiff legs
and all."
As it stands, Robert allowed my father to
keep his lands and title as Lord of the Iron
Islands, King of Salt and Rock, Son of the
Sea Wind, Lord Reaper of Pyke.
For a price.
His last son and heir shipped off to Winterfell
as an "honored guest."
I would eat at the Starks' table and play
with the Stark children.
And if my father rebelled again, Lord Eddard
Stark would take his sword and cut off my
head.
It would be his duty.
Stannis Baratheon: Though Robert had risked
all our lives to win it, the Iron Throne bored
him.
He cared little for justice and less for rule.
If it weren't women or wineskin, he had no
use for it.
Without the stalwart Jon Arryn as Hand of
the King, the challenge to Robert's crown
would have come much earlier than it did.
The Iron Islands have never lacked for treachery.
They respect only strength, and honor is as
foreign to them as the Seven.
After six years, their ruler, Lord Balon Greyjoy,
wagered that King Robert had not won the support
of the Great Houses of Westeros, many of whom
still named him "Usurper."
Lord Balon declared the Iron Islands independent
and sent his Iron Fleet to Lannisport.
Lord Tywin Lannister was careless, and the
ironborn burnt his ships at anchor.
Lord Balon and his reavers controlled the
Sunset Sea.
Robert then ordered me to succeed where his
father-in-law, Lord Tywin, had failed.
Beneath Robert's fury, I sensed relief.
War, he could understand.
He would smash Lord Balon as he had Rhaegar.
I raised Robert's fleet and sailed around
Westeros to the Iron Islands.
I set a trap for the Iron Fleet off Fair Isle.
As sailors and warriors, the ironborn are
unparalleled, but they are not soldiers.
They have no discipline, no strategy, no unity.
In a battle, each man fights only for his
own glory, and their longships are built for
lightning strikes and shore raids.
When the captains rushed in, I smashed their
longships with our larger war galleys.
The strength of the ironborn is in their ships.
With the Iron Fleet broken, I had assured
Robert's victory.
He could now transport troops and siege weapons
to invade the Iron Islands, and contrary to
Balon's hopes, Robert had plenty of both.
I've never seen such allegiances Robert could
inspire in war.
Enemies who tried to kill him one day would
be drinking with him the next under their
own fallen banners.
In rebelling against the Iron Throne, Lord
Balon did more than Robert ever could to cement
his rule.
When Robert came to the Iron Islands, he brought
with him the full power of Westeros.
Ser Barristan Selmy of the Kingsguard led
the assault on Old Wyk while I subdued Great
Wyk, the largest of the Iron Islands.
But Robert saved the seat of House Greyjoy,
Pyke, for himself and Lord Eddard.
Robert would later boast of the battle's bloodiness
and how he could have torn down the island
into the waves if Lord Balon had not bent
the knee.
But if I had led the assault, Balon's neck
would have bent under a sword.
Because I do not forget or pardon.
His time will come.
All their times will come.
Yara Greyjoy: The Seven are gods of weakness
and defeat, pretty chains that the First Men
kindly put on after the Andals crushed them,
except in the Iron Islands.
Since the Dawn Age, the Ironborn have followed
the Drowned God, who plucked fire from the
sea and made us to reave and sack and carve
our names in blood and song.
When the Andals landed on the Iron Islands,
they found a god who was Father, Warrior,
and Stranger; who took Mother, Maiden, and
Crone when he would; and held the Smith in
thrall.
His priests are Drowned Men, who are clothed
and armed by the sea itself.
They consecrate us to the Drowned God through
our most sacred rite, the Drowning, and ask
the God to raise them from the sea as he was,
harder and stronger.
The ironborn do not fear the bloodiest battle
or the roughest waves, for the Drowned God
taught us long ago that what is dead may never
die.
When an Ironborn falls, we say that the Drowned
God needed a strong oarsman and took him below
to feast in the God's watery halls, attended
by mermaids.
But even in death, an ironborn is a warrior.
We fight against the Storm God, who holds
a castle in the clouds and sends the winds
to lure the ironborn off course or wreck their
ships.
It's said my legendary ancestor, the Grey
King, waged war against upon the Storm God
for a thousand years.
With the Drowned God's help, he slew the great
Sea Dragon Nagga and used her bones for his
hall.
After his death, the Storm God tried to wash
away any memory of this terrible foe, but
his songs fill our halls to this day.
It was the Storm God who first blew the Andals
to the Iron Islands; to subdue us and turn
us from our faith.
True, they conquered and killed our king;
but in time, they forsook their septs for
the shore and their fat Septons for the Drowned
Men.
The Andals came to us conquerors; in the end,
they drowned.
The ironborn are of the sea, as our God made
us, and given to it as our God taught us.
We do not fear the Storm God's winds or his
waves.
But you should, for they bring us to you.